loves screen great comedians up talking
pictures is going to present a special
honorary Oscar tonight 30 years ago he
got his own it was given to him by the
president then Charles bracket on the
25th annual Wars
I don't
it was time to stretch huh
thank you very much this is a unique
role for me giving instead of accepting
hasn't really been 30 years it's funny I
looked the same but the cue cards are a
little further away well when a man
reaches my age which I intend to do
shortly he realizes there's more to life
than Awards there's the esteem of your
fellow man the respect of your
colleagues the admiration of your peers
none of which I have but this was my
most successful year at the movie box
office they lowered the price for senior
citizens and if you wonder why I didn't
make a picture last year when et called
home my agent answered the phone anyway
just let me tell you I'm not here to
talk about me as fascinating as the
subject is I'm here to present an
honorary Oscar to a star who has worked
so long he's had to use three different
names Joey jr. Mickey McGuire and Mickey
Rooney there isn't a longer more
luxurious or varied screen career than
his from infancy to childhood through
adolescent to manhood his powers as a
performer have never diminished over the
60 years he can still sing dance tell a
joke and tear your heart out yes this
man never in the history of our theatre
has so much astonishing talent been
jammed into one compact package before
his second birthday little Mick busted
out of his bassinet cramped out onto the
stage and stole his parents laudable act
he's been guilty of grand theft ever
since
the Board of Governors and it's
delightful wisdom has voted this
honorary Oscar to the kid who eliminated
all our yesterday's and to the man who
brightens all our today's to you make
with low
ladies and gentlemen members of the
Academy this is for sixty years of work
so they tell me
it's really only four six minutes of fun
of love and joy of working with playing
with like children the people that we
all are on the screen I love every
minute that God has given me to be an
infinitesimal small part of this great
business 60 years gosh I tonight for my
being here and the responsibility really
belongs to somebody that I'd love to put
my arms around like Judy Garland and
Lewis stone Faye Holden
Spencer Tracy Wallace Beery memories I
have a lot of memories as we all do when
I was 19 years old I was the number one
star of the world for two years when I
was 40 nobody wanted me I couldn't get a
job and then a professor from the
University of Tennessee got a show
together with Terry Allen Kramer and
Harry Rigby called sugarbabyz and it
resurrected my career
last year God smiled upon me and I was
given the Emmy for Bill and I won the
Peabody Award in the Golden Globe and
tonight you honor me beyond anything
that a man should be given you honor me
with the greatest and the highest
tribute we can receive in our business
my family all love you and they're all
tingling inside because of this moment
for me
I'd love to even kiss Louie be mayor but
it's it's wonderful the woman who put it
all together was Ruth Webb my agent -
who picked out the pieces picked up the
pieces and put them back together Mickey
jr. Timmy teddy
Kelly Carey Kyle Kimmie sue Jimmy Joe
Nell Chris and Mark and my grandchildren
the my grandchildren Shannon and Nica
they're home tonight looking and saying
that's granddaddy up there and he's got
the Oscar but the one that's responsible
outside of God is my wife Jan who kept
saying to me for the last seven years I
know you can do it make get up off the
canvas you can do it I want to thank you
one and all for remembering me thank you
for this glorious moment god bless
you